a big question on everybody's list
chapped lips
[Music]
what the hell
morning
uh see the groundhog
I think it'll be an early spring
didn't we do this yesterday
I don't know what you mean no don't mess
with me pork chop what day is this it's
February 2nd
Groundhog Day
you know I thought it was yesterday
oh
[Laughter]
did you sleep well Mr Connors
did I sleep well
would you like some coffee yes please I
think I'll have a double
I hope you enjoy the festivities
there's talk of a blizzard
do you ever have Deja Vu Mrs Lancaster
I don't think so but I could check with
the kitchen
no that's okay thank you
will you be checking out today Mr
Connors
I'd say the chance of departure is 80
percent
75.80
excuse me
excuse me where's everybody going
to Gobbler's Knob
it's Groundhog Day
it's still just once a year isn't it
I'm sorry what was that again
I'm a God you're God
I'm a God I'm not the god I don't think
because you survived a car wreck you
folks ready to order I didn't just
survive a wreck I wasn't just blown up
yesterday I have been stabbed shot
poisoned Frozen hung electrocuted and
burned oh really
every morning I wake up without a
scratch on me not a dent in the fender
I am an immortal
special today is blueberry waffles
why are you telling me this because I
want you to believe in me
you're not a God you can take my word
for it this is 12 years of Catholic
School talking
I could come back if you're not ready
how do you know I'm not a god
Oh please how do you know
DARS
this is Doris her brother-in-law Carl
owns this Diner she's worked here since
she was 17. more than anything else in
her life she wants to see Paris before
she dies oh boy what are you doing this
is Debbie kleiser and her fiance Fred do
I know you they're supposed to be
getting married this afternoon but
Debbie is having second thoughts what
lovely ring
it's Bill he's been a waiter for three
years since he left Penn State and had
to get work he likes the town he paints
toy soldiers and he's gay I am
this is Gus he hates his life here he
wished he stayed in the Navy well I
could have retired on half pay after 20
years
mate
well maybe the real God uses tricks you
know maybe he's not omnipotent he's just
been around for a long he knows
everything oh okay well who's that this
is Tom we work in the coal mine till
they close the town her it's Alice came
over here from Ireland when she was a
baby she lived in Erie most of her life
and her Nancy she works in the dress
shop and makes noises like a chipmunk
when she gets real excited
that's true how do you know these people
I told you I know everything in about
five seconds a waiter's gonna drop a
tray of dishes five four three two one
okay
when check off saw The Long Winter
he saw a winter Bleak and dark and
bereft of Hope
yet we know that winter is just another
step in the cycle of life
but standing here among the people of
Punxsutawney
and basking in the warmth of their
hearths and hearts
I couldn't imagine a better fate than a
long and lustrous winter
from Punxsutawney it's Phil Connors
so long
[Applause]
how was that for you too amen you
touched me thanks Larry thank you
that was surprising I didn't know you
were so versatile I surprised myself
sometimes well where are you going would
you like to get a cup of coffee I'd love
to can I have a rain check I've got some
errands I've got to run okay
Phil Aaron Aaron's what errands I
thought we were going back
[Music]
what do you say what do you say what do
you say you little brat you have never
thanked me
I'll see you tomorrow
Maybe
oh
totaled it
no it's only a flat tired
it's an earthquake
oh thank you young man
it's nothing ma'am I had to tie around
the Jack just be comfortable all right
be a minute
[Music]
Phil Phil Connors I thought that was you
oh you know this is Ned Ryerson he's my
new insurance agent I'll say
I have not seen this guy for 20 years he
comes up to me and then he buys whole
life term uniflex fire Theft Auto Dental
Health with the optional death and
dismemberment plan water damage Phil
this is the best day of my life mine too
mine too where are we going oh let's not
spoil it
oh let's not oh I got that
oh
why can't I look
if you could bother me a lot I'm getting
cold
how much longer do you have to sit here
I'm just trying to give you your money's
worth you paid top dollar for me
well I think you were a bargain
sweetie to say you're probably right
[Laughter]
finished yet
almost I still have to put some cherry
syrup on the top and then we can eat it
come on Phil I'm freezing one second
let me turn blade
it's amazing
how did you do that
I know your face so well I could have
done it with my eyes closed
it's lovely
I don't know what to say
I do
no matter what happens tomorrow
or for the rest of my life
I'm happy now
because I love you
[Music]
I think I'm happy